the reality is we cannot ignore the
buildup of over a hundred thousand
troops on the ukrainian border
and the attempts to undermine ukrainian
sovereignty
and territorial integrity
fundamentally a war in ukraine would be
disastrous for the russian and ukrainian
people
and for european security
and together nato has made it clear that
any incursion into ukraine would have
massive consequences
and carry severe costs
there is an alternative route
a diplomatic route
that avoids conflict and bloodshed
and as you say this would enable us to
build ties
this morning i visited the moscow state
university
and saw the excellent russian
mathematicians
in action
as fellow permanent members of the
security council
i am here to urge russia to take that
path
as p5 members we are already working to
stop iran acquiring nuclear weapons to
improve global security
russia could enhance its stature
as a p5 member
by abandoning cold war rhetoric and
instead engaging in meaningful
discussions with nato to improve
european security
but these discussions must respect
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
as russia freely signed up to in the
1994
budapest memorandum
if these principles are respected
i believe that in today's talks we can
make progress to strengthen security for
all